hi everybody i'm brian kilmeade and this
is tucker carlson tonight tucker will be
with you in about five minutes but we do
have some breaking news we want to share
with you of course today was dominated
by many stories one of which was the
bipartisan budget bill for butter
security and the big number is that the
president was not happy with was one
point three seven five billion to build
a border barrier he could do whatever he
wanted with it which shows an advantage
but the question was with the president
add something with that would he declare
a national emergency I just got off the
phone with Mick Mulvaney chief of staff
and the answer is a resounding yes
and for the first time you're going to
hear exactly how much it is and where
the money's coming from it's going to be
about eight billion dollars he had the
one point three then six hundred million
will come from the Treasury the Treasury
forfeiture fund two point five billion
out of DoD they consulted with McMahon E
and the White House over the last few
months on what they could actually do
and they're going to use some money they
feel they can spare on the drug
interdiction interdiction account then
they came across with three point five
billion for the military the military
construction budget they feel they can
help in that respect and then of course
they have additional money it all leads
adds up to eight billion dollars so the
one point three seven five not enough
for the president he wanted five point
seven he walks away at the end of the
day with eight billion dollars and of
course the Democrats and some
Republicans are upset about that